excusez moi monsieur je suis désolé mais
c'est vraiment très dangereux de fumer
près des pompes la station entière
pourrait prendre feu j'ai simplement un
petit problème et je sais que vous n'y
êtes pour rien mais je vais quand même
vous demander un peu de coopération
quand tout sera fini vous aurez une
histoire d'un gars à côté est en train
de braquer c'est bien ça en fait nous on
n'a pas la clé du coffre fort je vais
chercher l'âge tu as besoin de combien
la totalité d'accord emmène moi je
voudrais partir avec toi
c'est vraiment une petite [ __ ] avec
une arme menaçant de filles
prends ton argent et dégage d'ici comme
la petite [ __ ] potec cet individu
était relativement douteux c'est à dire
qu'ont ils étaient j'étais doute toit
fermé la porte à clé vous savez vous
posez vos rares il ressembler à quoi
melinda
[Musique]
je dis d'attendre dans les toilettes
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que tu diras la police quand
elle sera là
[Musique]
je n'ai aucune je ne pensais pas que
chez la sq avait tiré dessus c'est parce
que je voulais si je ne rapporte pas
l'argent ils vont et je cite m'attacher
à l'arrière de leur moto et me traîner
sur la route jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste
plus rien de mois
bon une sacrée première nuit
elle est complètement folle elle met à
couler le designer non
ah ah
[Musique]
en 2047 la révolution a bien eu lieu
ce que chaque homme devrait s'en tenir à
son périmètre attitré autrement il
devient nécessaire de le remettre dans
le droit chemin
la moindre condamnation suspecte de
programme signature
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
aux éternels n'aurais-je pas de haine
pour ceux qui te haïssent du dégoût pour
ceux qui s'élèvent contre toi
regarde si je suis sur une mauvaise voie
[Musique]
ton jour viendra bientôt mais tu dois
être fort
tous ceux qui l'invoquent utilise le nom
de vierges sanglante pas moi j'ai
effectué le rituel correctement c'est
pour ça qu'elle est apparue catharines
mais je comprends pas pourquoi elle
s'est échappée on va passer au plan de
nos élèves est tombé en syncope dans les
toilettes ils demandent à ce que vous
interveniez dans notre collège pour
éliminer la vierge sanglante quatre
demeuraient qui font un film d'horreur
notre travail et sermonné des
exterminateurs d'euphorie et des
influenceurs d'un fermier
vous m'avez l'air d'une belle bande de
clowns
pas question que je joue encore les
fantômes tous ceux qui prennent les
fantômes au sérieux finisse comme toi je
crois que les enfants sont en danger
[Applaudissements]
la bière sanglante disputés elle est
bien réelle
cette chose que vous avez dit vient d'un
autre monde c'est quoi cette nuit
non mais vous foutez de moi je met pas
cette mère d'un mec comme on t'a fait
elle était possédé est-ce que je suis
obligé de me raser la barbe est ce
qu'une gamine de 13 ans à de la barre
est-ce qu'une gamine de 13 ans à une
quête ses fils deux des membres
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas toi je pense un peu quand même
si ça finit en eau de boudin ça ne
changera pas ma carrière quand est ce
que tu vas arrêter traîner avec ces bons
à rien de fait
tout va bien se passer maintenant que
madame helena et l'arrêt tu crois ou
chez les bisounours petite merde
c'est pas la peine de me pousser
c'est pas la peine j'ai toujours eu les
meilleures sa tension quelqu'un incendié
votre maison sachant que vous étiez
intérieur
lna connaissez vous quelqu'un qui aurait
pu faire ça le loyer de 300 dollars par
mois ce qui est très en dessous du
marché
de toute façon avec mon mari on ne fait
pas ça pour l'argent et acceptait de lui
louer sans garantie temps c'est un peu
plus sur elle vous travaillez dans quoi
je suis artiste va proposer à cette
femme de venir travailler chez nous
c'est très valorisant de savoir que vos
actions peuvent embellir la vie d'une
autre personne
c'est difficile pour toutes les mères
quand il ya de l'argent ça se voit moins
il ya une chose qu'on ne peut pas
acheter c'est l'amour d'une mère
pourquoi tu détache pas tes cheveux
maman c'est de loin son meilleur atout
alors comme ça il n'y a que vous deux où
on déménage souvent pour le boulot de ma
mère elle cache des trucs tout le monde
a ses petits secrets
j'ai contacté la personne que vous avez
cités comme étant votre ancien
propriétaire sur le bail et bizarrement
il a dit qu'il ne vous connaissais pas
si tu veux vivre dans ma maison tu dois
respecter mes règles
qui a dit que tu devez l'accepter sans
rien dire si toi tu ne fais rien pour
défendre ses actuels qui le fera elle
est profondément à filtrer dans notre
vie j'ai besoin de savoir qui est
vraiment cette femme
[Musique]
on a tous des pardons pour qu'ils nous
aient frère tu vraiment prêt pouvant
cacher cette histoire
[Musique]
auquel on essaie d'échapper tu m'as
sommet dit la vérité sur rien
[Musique]
plus partie de nous mêmes que nous
refusons de voir tu perds complètement
ton sang-froid inquiète pas je suis
parfaitement calme
[Musique]
le monde finira par payer pour ce qu'il
a fait
je suis au courant de votre petit secret
est ce que c'est une menace
bonjour le cosmos xbee de la planète
avec le plus de déchets de l'univers la
terre
non
[Musique]
notre enquête aujourd'hui mais roubaud
sur terre
[Applaudissements]
culinaire à la découverte
[Musique]
un comportement nous interrogent les
humains sont-ils l'espèce la plus
compliquée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en janvier afin
elise et pour blocage
[Musique]